they say that if walls could talk
each building would have a story to tell
but few would tell
so many fascinating stories in so many
different voices as the highest sophia
or holy wisdom perched at the crossroads
of continents and cultures
it has seen massive changes from the
name of the city where it stands
to its own structure and purpose and
today the elements from each era stand
ready to tell their tales to any visitor
who will listen
even before you arrive at the haya
sophia the ancient fortifications hint
at the strategic importance of the
surrounding city
founded as byzantium by greek colonists
in 657 bce
and successfully renamed as augusta
antonia new rome and constantinople
as it was conquered re-conquered
destroyed and rebuilt by various greek
persian and roman rulers over the
following centuries
and it was within these walls that the
first megala ecclesia
or great church was built in the 4th
century though it was soon burned to the
ground in riots it established the
location for the region's main religious
structure for centuries to come
near the entrance the marble stones with
reliefs are the last reminders of the
second church
built in 415 ce it was destroyed during
the nika riots of 532 when angry crowds
at a chariot race nearly overthrew the
emperor justinian the first
having barely managed to retain power he
resolved to rebuild the church on a
grander scale
and five years later the edifice you see
before you
was completed as you step inside the
stones of the foundation and walls
murmur tales from their homelands of
egypt and syria
while columns taken from the temple of
artemis recall a more ancient past
runic inscriptions carved by the vikings
of the emperor's elite guard
carry the lore of distant northern lands
but your attention is caught by the
grand dome
representing the heavens reaching over
50 meters high
and over 30 meters in diameter and
ringed by windows around its base
the golden dome appears suspended from
heaven light reflecting through its
interior
beneath its grandiose symbolism the
sturdy reinforcing corinthian columns
brought from lebanon after the original
dome was partially destroyed by an
earthquake in 558 ce
quietly remind you of its fragility and
the engineering skills such a marvel
requires
if a picture is worth a thousand words
the mosaics from the next several
centuries have the most to say not only
about their biblical themes
but also the byzantine emperors who
commissioned them often depicted along
with christ
but beneath their loud and clear voices
one hears the haunting echoes of the
damaged and missing mosaics and icons
desecrated and looted during the latin
occupation in the fourth crusade
within the floor the tomb inscription of
enrico dendalo
the venetian ruler who commanded the
campaign is a stark reminder of those 57
years
that hayes sophia spent as a roman
catholic church
before returning to its orthodox roots
upon the byzantine reconquest
but it would not remain a church for
long weakened by the crusades
constantinople fell to the ottomans in
and would be known as istanbul
thereafter after allowing his soldiers
three days of pillage
sultan mehmet ii entered the building
though heavily damaged its grandeur was
not lost on the young sultan who
immediately
rededicated it to allah proclaiming that
it would be the new
imperial mosque the four minarets built
over the next century are the most
obvious sign of this era
serving as architectural supports in
addition to their religious purpose
but there are many others ornit candle
holders relate suleiman's conquest of
hungary
while giant calligraphy disks hung from
the ceiling remind visitors for the
first four caliphs who followed muhammad
though the building you see today still
looks like a mosque
it is now a museum a decision made in
by kamal ataturk the modernizing first
president of turkey
following the ottoman empire's collapse
it was this secularization that allowed
for removal of the carpets hiding the
marble floor decorations
and the plaster covering the christian
mosaics
ongoing restoration work has allowed the
multiplicity of voices in haya sophia's
long history to be heard again
after centuries of silence but conflict
remains
hidden mosaics cry out from beneath
islamic calligraphy
valuable pieces of history that cannot
be uncovered without destroying others
meanwhile calls sound from both muslim
and christian communities to return the
building to its former religious
purposes
the story of the divine wisdom may be
far from over
but one can only hope that the many
voices residing there
will be able to tell their part for
years to come
you